every now and then the women folk of our
town like to enjoy a day off from bending
over a hot kitchen stove and scrubbing dirty
dishes we don't have to search for an answer
to that desire because we have sufficient
restaurants with nice atmosphere and good
clean wholesome food at reasonable prices
right in our own community the men may
grumble at the suggestion let's heat out
tonight but just watch them enjoy that food
feel safe and proud of our municipal government
for it is through this force that our town is
kept in order and protected from unlawful
and disrupting influences it's a mighty good
feeling to know they are always on the job to
make our town a better place in which to live
we are proud of our excellent schools that
provide the education of our children proud
of its part toward preparing our use for facing
the future our schools are properly organized
with able staffs educated to guide and teach
these future young men and women of tomorrow
our town looks with pride to its fine automobile
agencies and services beautiful new cars are
rolling off the assembly lines daily offering
more room more style more convenience longer
service and lasting quality our dealers are
doing their utmost to put as many new cars
on our streets as possible here as everywhere
else we have waited for these necessities and
luxuries and now we can feel sure that we will
be supplied with finer products than ever before
our service clubs might well be called the
backbone of our town for it is through them
that our business and social activities are
welded together their noble and unselfish
efforts are aimed at making ours a
better town in which to live and work
through these clubs many a good deed
has been bestowed upon our fellow man